I have this reoccurring dream I feel the
warmth of the Sun on my skin and the
comfort of arms around me and I want to
stay there forever but that would be
impossible I have a severe sensitivity
to sunlight doctor appointments became a
part of my routine it's not gonna fall
into remission and every year the risk
becomes more serious so I spend all my
time indoors behind special windows
sleeping during the day and staying up
all night and playing music every chance
I get
Hey what should I have said hey I'm
Katie Price I've watched outside my
window for the past 10 years that I've
been in love with you stalking you every
minute this is what Taylor's chef does
she has awkward interactions with boys
and then she just writes amazing songs
father I don't understand how we've
never met I've probably skated by your
house every day on the way to practice
hey you would want to do something
sometime would you I'm really busy
during the day but I could be free at
night
[Music]
what does Katie price want to do there's
so many things I want to do he's taking
me first live show that was literally
one of the best things that are right
I'll be a dream until the dad coming
I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer being someone more than
just a disease this isn't something you
can just not tell me I'm so sorry but
we're not the couple who doesn't try
[Music]
I'm putting my whole life to feel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]